>>> NEW YEAR'S COMES WITH
HOLIDAY CHEER AND PLENTY OF
RESOLUTIONS TO DO BETTER NEXT
YEAR.
YES, FRIENDS, THAT MARKED MY ONE
AND ONLY HOLIDAY RHYME FOR YOU
THIS SEASON, BUT WE DO HAVE SOME
NEW INSIGHTS FOR YOU NO WHY SOME
PEOPLE STICK TO THEIR
RESOLUTIONS AND SOME DO NOT.
CNN'S HARRY ENTON JOINS ME NOW
WITH THE NUMBERS.
HARRY, WE'VE GOT ONE WEEK TO GET
READY.
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
MAKE NEW YEAR'S RESOLUTIONS?
>> WELL, THIS IS WHAT I FOUND SO
INTERESTING IS IF YOU ASK THEM
NOW JUST BEFORE THE NEW YEAR ARE
YOU GOING TO MAKE A RESOLUTION?
THEY SAY 43% SAY YES ON AVERAGE
SINCE 2015, BUT LOOK HERE, SAY
THEY ACTUALLY MADE ONE AFTER THE
NEW YEAR WHEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
THEY REALIZE I MIGHT HAVE TO
ACTUALLY KEEP TO IT.
ONLY 29% SAY YES SO FOUR IN TEN
WILL SAY YES AND ONCE WE HIT THE
NEW YEAR IT WILL BE ONLY BE
ABOUT THREE IN TEN.
>> THAT TRACKS WITH MY
MENTALITY.
I'M NOT SPEAKING FOR MYSELF BUT
HOW WELL DO PEOPLE STICK TO NEW
YEAR'S RESOLUTIONS?
I FIND THIS MASS FATING.
>> YEAH, LOOK, THIS -- IF YOU
ASK THEM AFTER THE YEAR IS DONE.
OKAY, HAVE YOU ACTUALLY STUCK TO
YOUR NEW YEAR'S RESOLUTION, LOOK
TO THIS?
68% SAY YES.
AT LEAST PARTIALLY, BUT, OF
COURSE, THAT'S ONLY AMONG THE
ONES WHO MAKE ONE AND SAY THEY
MADE ONE, SO IT'S THAT 68% OF
THAT SAY 28% OR 29% WHO SAID
THAT THEY MADE ONE AFTER THE NEW
YORE SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AROUND IS ABOUT 20% OF FOLKS WHO
ACTUALLY MAKE A NEW YEAR'S
RESOLUTION AND SAY THEY KEEP TO
IT IN THE ENTIRE POPULATION, SO
MAYBE YOU'RE ONE OF THOSE WHO
RIGHT NOW IS SAYING YOU KNOW
WHAT I'LL MAKE ONE BUT THEN, YOU
KNOW, AFTER THE NEW YEAR YOU
ACTUALLY DECIDE I'M GOING TO TRY
AND DO IT AND OF THAT PROPORTION
ONLY ABOUT 68% ACTUALLY ARE ABLE
TO KEEP IT AT LEAST PARTIALLY.
>> ARE THERE TRENDS HERE?
ARE ANY RESOLUTIONS MOST
POPULAR?
>> YEAH, THERE ARE A FEW, A
FEW.
NOT NECESSARILY THE ONES THAT I
WOULD DO.
>> YOU READ MY MIND.
>> RIGHT, EXACTLY.
>> EXERCISE MORE.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S
NECESSARILY IN MY FUTURE.
EAT HEALTHIER.
YOU'VE ACTUALLY BEEN DOING THAT
HALF DECENTLY.
SAVE MORE MONEY.
I HAVE TO ADMIT THAT'S SOMETHING
I DO FAIRLY WELL.
SPEND MORE TIME WITH FAMILY,
MAYBE.
BE A BETTER PERSON.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT ALL OF US
CAN DO.
GET A NEW JOB.
GOOD NEWS, LIKE MY JOB AND QUIT
SMOKING.
MY MOTHER WAS A PEDIATRICIAN AND
TWO THINGS SHE MADE ME PROMISE
TO DO, ALWAYS WEAR A SEAT BELT
IN THE CAR AND NEVER SMOKE AND I
DO BOTH OF THOSE.
>> YET AGAIN I SPEAK FOR
EVERYONE OUT THERE TO SAY THAT
THIS SEGMENT IS NOT ABOUT YOU,
BUT WE CAN CONTINUE.
I'M SCARED TO ASK BUT WHAT IS
YOUR RESOLUTION?
>> A NEW NEW YEAR'S RESOLUTIONS.
NUMBER UP, I ACTUALLY WANT TO
EXIRSIZE.
I WANT TO BE LESS PAVES.
I WANT TO BE LESS PASSIVE.
I KNOW I COME ACROSS PERHAPS
AGGRESSIVE IN THE AIR BUT
BASICALLY IN REAL LIFE I'M
AFRAID OF SPEAKING MY MIND
SOMETIMES AND MOST IMPORTANT I
WANT TO PET EVEN MORE DOGS, SHIH
TZU AND LHASA APSOS I LOVE THEM.
>> I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU WHAT
YOUR RESOLUTION GOING TO BE.
IT'S GOING TO BE BUY NEW SHOES
TO WEAR AT WORK.
IF YOU SEE HARRY